welcome to another dr sadler's honest
reviews this is a series in which i
review
mostly recent works in practical
philosophy in a very broad sense which
would include philosophy proper you know
a lot of ethics things but also
extending over into studies about
leadership or psychology or self-help
and everything in between now the book
that i'm reviewing today is actually
very solidly within practical philosophy
in a technical and academic sense it is
john cellars the art of living the
stoics on the nature and function of
philosophy the second edition
of the work and it's it's not really all
that recent as a matter of fact so this
edition published in
2009 the first edition was published in
2003 and you might say well you know
usually you're reviewing recent books
why are you going back in time to
reviewing this one well it's i'll put it
to you this way it's an excellent work
that i'm going to be highly recommending
as we go on further in the video but
there's also a little bit of backstory
here so one of my viewers
emailed me and said you know would you
be willing to review
this book i know that you typically do
you know books from just a few years ago
but i really like it and i think that
you would get something out of it now i
actually had a first edition of it the
hardcover as well and i said well if you
send me the most recent edition sure
i'll review it and so i'm gonna thank
right away
dominic
escor peso for having me sent this copy
it's been a while you know so he's been
waiting for me to get around to
reviewing it
and i'm very happy to be able to do that
at this time i'm also going to make a
disclosure up front as well
john sellers is both a friend and a
colleague of mine we're both members of
the modern stoicism organization and
we've interacted a number of times as
well so that doesn't actually
influence my my review of the work
because this is such a great work it
would stand on its own so i'll tell you
why that's the case
as usual i'm gonna first talk about some
basics the the style the summary of the
work structure of the work then i'll go
into some of the key ideas and there's
many key ideas in this we'll talk about
some of the good points and there's many
to this work and then we'll talk about
anything that i found problematic
there's not an awful lot of that with
this particular text but there are a few
things that i'll bring up so
no further ado let's jump into the
review
style structure summary the big three
s's which of these should we approach
first let's start with
summarizing what this work is
so you know the title gives some of it
away the stoics on the nature and
function of philosophy that's the
subtitle it's a little bit more
technical the art of living okay that's
a big big broad conception and i think
that actually these two play off well
against each other for giving you an
idea about what the book is doing uh
summarizing the
progression of the book so it is
beginning with talking about the art of
living which is
in fact
one of the very many different
definitions of philosophy that are
provided out there
and it is one that that some stoics in
fact used
but it's not a uniquely stoic idea and
that's part of what john sellers is
trying to bring across
and the stoics are not the first to come
up with this notion of philosophy as
being involved in one's life as being
practical as being an art about how to
make decisions how to live how to
prioritize how to do all these sorts of
things that are so central to not just
individual instances but an entire
life and the process of living so that
is part of what the book is about is
exploring not just what the stoics have
to say about it but also the prior
philosophers
and you know these are going to be
people who come to influence the stoics
but also
those who criticize or
are skeptical towards the stoic and
other perspectives on this as well so
you know if you haven't got a big
background in ancient philosophy this
book will actually help you out in that
in some respects now um structure let's
talk about that i mean you can always
know what the structure of a book is by
looking at the table of contents and
it's divided into two main parts part
one is there's these greek terms bios
and techne right so bios means life
uh a life that one lives right and
techne is you often translate it as art
or craft it's a word we get technical
from and technique from the second part
two more greek terms uh part two logos
and escases right so logos is the word
that we get logic from
and all of those ologies that you might
have studied like biology is the logos
about bios the logos about life um and
then ascasis this is the word that we
get ascetic from not aesthetic but
ascetic and it has to do with discipline
with conditioning oneself with exercises
with practices all of those sorts of
things so what are the connections
between
these two things in each of the sections
and um you know the first part has has
uh four chapters the second part has
three chapters then there's a conclusion
one of the things that you'll find is
that each chapter itself has a sort of
conclusion called the summary where um
he's well actually not every single one
part uh
chapter five doesn't have that now that
i'm looking at it but every other
chapter does have a summary and they're
all you know bringing things to kind of
a useful close you're going to find a
bit of repetition in the book but it's
it's needed repetition
and it begins understandably enough with
an introduction actually prior to that
there's the preface to the second
edition where john says i'm delighted
duckworth is publishing this paperback
edition first published in hardback in
2003. i'm especially pleased it will
take its place along the many respected
volumes already published in the series
my hope is it will now reach a much
wider audience than it than it has thus
far and i i think that has actually been
realized and he talks a little bit in
the preface about you know some of the
rethinking that he has done and why what
was the purpose behind writing this book
and we're going to come back to that
when we go to the key ideas of the book
there's a number of abbreviations
because it's kind of a academic work and
then there's the introduction where he
you know brings us into the topic tells
us what he's going to be doing in the
various chapters and then gets into them
now i'll run through the the chapters in
just a moment but i do want to point out
something else that's really quite nice
about this book after the conclusion
there are
additional notes
right this is um and this is you know
not a very long book by the way this is
this book is about
okay so including all of the index about
228 pages long so it's not particularly
long it is rather dense but there's
these additional notes so there's an
additional note on socrates that talks
about the
so-called socratic problem how much of
this stuff that we're getting in plato
is really socrates and how much is plato
and all that and there's so there's some
discussion about that then there's a
note on
stoicism who who counts as a stoic right
there's another note on the text of
epictetus that tells us about the
discourses or dissertations and then
there's another note on the text of
marcus aurelius the meditations
then i think this is very helpful for
a non-greek reading reader there's a
glossary of greek words and phrases
beginning with anthropos
and going on for uh
four pages all the way down to tsuke
right so this is this is a nice feature
of the work there's a guide to ancient
philosophers and authors
this is probably also quite helpful for
somebody who doesn't have a big big
background in ancient thought then
there's a bibliography that i think is
probably more for the academic reader
you know
i don't imagine too many other people
consulting it and then there's an index
of uh
places you know what where are the texts
and
[Music]
a general index as well so it's this is
a book that is actually
written to accommodate
scholarship academic readers but also
uh ordinary people who are literate and
interested in these
issues in ancient philosophy
the last thing i need to talk about
is the style because we'll we'll talk
about the particular points of the
chapters
in the next section
so
i think john is a great writer
this is
as far as i'm concerned very readable
it is written in academic prose but it's
not the kind of prose
that is
overly jargon-laden whenever there's a
discussion going on about some technical
point there'll be some explanation about
what the what the words mean and you
know there's a lot of
great sort of background encapsulated in
this examples are being used so this is
a this is a book i think that you know
would be fairly easy for
a non-specialist to get a lot out of and
it's almost like an initiation
into
the language and the ways of approaching
these things that you know scholarship
on ancient philosophy
bring so i think this could actually
function
in many respects as a book that draws
the reader in
and educates them along the way so
that's the three s's let's talk now
about some of the main points of the
work
i suppose that if you were going to
restrict me to saying just one thing
about the work
telling you what the main point the main
argument the main thrust of the work is
it would be that in ancient philosophy
philosophy was conceived of as something
that was a way of life not just a
matter of different
theoretical conceptions or arguments or
things like that
but something that was supposed to
transform our way of living and it was
an art of living it was not just you
know a bunch of ideas that then you
immediately apply there's something
practical to philosophy itself and that
runs throughout the entirety of this
work so that is a main point another key
idea that we see running throughout this
is that ancient philosophy
was not just a matter of treatises and
arguments and you know ideas that are
strung together not a matter just a
logoy right but it was also a matter of
storytelling about what it was that
ancient philosophers had done and what
they
said in particular instances how they
provided human beings with examples
you know and as well as discourses as
well as an interest in
theoretical and practical truth on the
other side as well
john sellers is really great about
bringing this home
it's not philosophy if it is
turned into just a set of practices what
we have nowadays call life hacks right
ancient philosophy is very very much
about practices you know they can be
called spiritual exercises they can be
called philosophical practices they can
be called all sorts of things and it's
also about little you know uh
things that people call quotes or
reminders or affirmations you know
maxims
but it isn't just about that there's a
cohesive framework to be a stoic
means to adopt a certain way of life to
be a cynic means to adopt another
certain way of life uh you know same
thing with even being a skeptic in
ancient times and so that's a very key
point there's a systematic
structure to doing philosophy that we
don't want to allow to be
lost another thing that comes out i said
i was going to talk about the preface so
another thing that really comes out here
that i think is very important
is that
sellers says that this is not just a
matter for ancient philosophy or modern
reinterpretations of ancient philosophy
this is something that we see
throughout the history of philosophy
up to our own time and he brings up you
know a number of different people he
mentions nietzsche he mentions hegel he
talks about this debate between richard
saragi and bernard williams both of whom
have been trained in the analytic
tradition there are a lot of different
people
who are are you know working with
something like philosophy as a way of
life and he he also talks about this in
the very end in the conclusion that it's
not just a
matter of
ancient or even medieval philosophy so
he brings up
you know
here's a great example throughout the
middle ages philosophers such as peter
abelard and john of salisbury drew on
the readily available latin works of
cicero and seneca not only for
philosophical ideas
but also for an understanding of the
nature
and function of philosophy as such
in the renaissance the same thing
happened we can see this in pet trucks
on the remedies of both kinds of fortune
in the 16th century the same occurred as
part of the explicit attempt to create a
neo-stoicism by eustace lipsius more
recently as i noted in the introduction
nietzsche developed his own version of
the conception of philosophy drawing on
his philological education and ancient
philosophy under the influence of
nietzsche foucault can also be seen to
turn to this technical conception of
philosophy and and we could come up with
so many other examples as well including
the work of john sellers himself right
who has enriched and contributed to this
this vast reservoir of philosophy as a
way of life
so broader
meta philosophical conceptions are at
play here to ask what kind of
what it what kind of art is philosophy
is asking about the nature of philosophy
and as he points out the function the
the purpose the end product of
philosophy
as well and so this brings us to one of
the key questions that is being grappled
with in the text what kind of art what
kind of techne
is philosophy and
sellers surveys a whole number of ideas
that are coming out of like for example
plato's gorgeous
and you know intrastoic debates right
and then epictetus later on and all
sorts of other people along the way so
i'm going to read a little bit more
from this just to give you a a sense of
the discussions that are
going on in this so in the apology
socrates holds up crafts people in
general is the only example you can find
of individuals possessing secure
knowledge
you know the question is well what kind
of techne do they have you know
in the gorgeous the arts that are
explicitly and used in relation to the
idea of an art taking care of one soul
or gymnastics gumnastique and medicine
yatrike these are both presented as
being concerned with the health of the
body with preserving or restoring a good
state to them they can be seen as
examples of stochastic arts right so
this is a distinction that gets made in
ancient times this stochastic notion
that people have been you know talking
about recently uh in in relation to
other things like stochastic terrorism
um it's an idea that comes from ancient
philosophy it's you know you you have a
sort of general thing that you can do
and you know if you have the technique
it will generally lead to success but
you know it's complicated factors so
perhaps it won't do that is the art of
living
that is philosophy
that kind of art
or is it a transformative art or is it
an art that produces a
guaranteed product you know
and so there's this entire review of
different kinds of techne right there's
acquisitive art there's a performative
art
there are
theoretical or contemplative arts there
are productive arts and this gets
reconsidered later on
when we're turning explicitly to the
stoics in in the chapter on that
and there's a discussion about you know
how
how similar is philosophy to medicine is
it a stochastic art like that you know
and and we come to be able to
distinguish between
the
art itself and having the art having the
principles
and producing the
effects that are connected to the
function of that art so these are some
really great distinctions that are worth
understanding and thinking through we
should talk about the structure of the
chapters
and what each chapter is concerned with
so the very first one philosophy and
biography right now why begin a book
talking about biography well because
sellers wants to stress to us that
in the way philosophy was being
understood in the ancient world life
and the discussion of a life mattered so
he begins with this interesting
sub-chapter the philosopher's beard
is it important to have a beard
as a philosopher why why is a beard
viewed as a sign
of philosophizing and he talks about you
know the difference between cicero on
this point and epictetus on this point
you know what shaving could mean
then he talks about erga deeds and logoi
discourses the philosopher's bios
meaning the life of the philosopher and
then he talks about biography right so
what are the biographies that we have
well we have plutarch who writes these
lives xenophons memorabilia which is you
know concerned in significant part with
socrates but there's you know xenophon
writes other things as well
um diogenes laertes um
life of diogenes the cynic you know
there's there's a very interesting life
one of the many lives that that figure
into diogenes layer taste porphyry's
life of platinus and each of these is a
different kind of philosophical
biography
and we see that they're all you know
playing a role in that then the next
chapter doesn't jump right into stoicism
it's called the socratic origins of the
art of living and it looks at uh
socrates and what we can get out of
xenophon
and what we can get out of you know some
of plato's texts and
it does some comparative work to
aristotle who is you know
two generations removed from socrates
and who also had some interesting ideas
the discussion here includes you know
the analysis of techne and the gorgeous
it's a nice short dialogue a lot of cool
stuff going on there if you haven't read
it it's worth reading and here's where
we get that discussion of the different
kinds of techne so that's already in
chapter
two uh and then it brings in the role of
ascasis what is this cases well
discipline is one way that we translate
it it's doing things doing exercises
habituating yourself and then we get an
interesting discussion of aristotle's
interpretation of socrates and then we
we have a conclusion
chapter three
gets us to what the title of the book
makes us think it's going to be about
the stoic conception of the art of
living and it turns out
that you know this is something that is
developmental the stoics are not all on
exactly the same page from the very
beginning and there's a lot of you know
each generation
thinking matters through both in
relation to their opponents or rival
schools but also in relation to
these socratic ideals that are coming to
them and their own fellow
stoics so there's a discussion in here
about you know the phrase the art of
living which we find in epictetus but we
find
analogs of it in other stoics the ideal
of the sage this is a really great
discussion of you know who the sage is
supposed to be maybe it's socrates maybe
it's diogenes maybe it's other people
and then we have this again turning to
discussion of art an art concerned
with the soul and we see these
discussions uh
referencing cicero referencing galen and
thereby chrysippus the important stoic
philosopher
and you know some differences between
this and he brings up again this is on
page 70
different types of art or craft and he
looks at you know whether
the art of living is a productive or
performative or stochastic art
and the stoics kind of differed on these
right
we get some discussion of seneca going
on in the relationship between escasis
and logos
and then we get into the stoic
division of philosophy into
physics ethics and logic
and here again we see that the stoics
they're not all on exactly the same
page
they have different conceptions of how
these are connected
with each other and you know
this is important to bring to mind
because i think a lot of people get
quite mixed up about this instead of
reading stoic texts this is a bit of an
aside or reading really quality
literature on stoicism they read lower
quality literature on stoicism that does
mention these three divisions
what kind of bollocks is things up so
you know this is this is a really great
chapter then
chapter four
turns us to a different school
the skeptics
why would would john sellers if he's
trying to develop the stoic conception
of the art of living
why would he go to the skeptics well
because the skeptics actually tell us
quite a bit about the stoics because the
skeptics are arguing against the stoics
but the skeptics also
have in mind
a certain way
of living so he talks about the
skeptical method
sexist empiricus has arguments against
there being an art of living that
certainly have to be
addressed and thought through
and then and this is actually quite a
long section then we have philosophy and
biography and skepticism and we find out
that the skeptics themselves are not an
exception to this rule that in ancient
philosophy it is important to think
about how one lives the skeptics
themselves are advocating a way of life
let me get to part two right this logos
and escasis part
and the the first chapter in there is
about philosophical exercises so if
you're somebody who's into you know
foucault's history of sexuality where he
talks about you know these techniques of
the self or you're into pirando or you
know other people uh thinking along
those lines talking about spiritual
exercises
well
sellers is going to be talking about
that as well and this brings you know
back the uh importance of escasis and
how that's connected the concept of a
spiritual exercise and he actually talks
about our dough there as well as other
people
and um then you know we we get to the
function what is the point of spiritual
exercises and he you know he focuses
rightly on habituation but then there's
an interesting section here on digestion
it's not just stimulus response
we're supposed to
learn through doing exercises
how to
you know live a better life and part of
that is you might say building the
muscles
involved then he talks about the
mechanism of spiritual exercises and the
form of spiritual exercises how do these
work and this is the one chapter without
a summary
the next two chapters
are ostensibly about two really really
key texts and sellers is using these
as you know kind of case studies so the
first one is on the handbook or the end
coridian of epictetus and he you know
tells us about the what the handbook is
and he brings in some plickeyuses um
commentary simplicious is by the way is
not a stoic he is a neoplatonous
philosopher writing several centuries
after epictetus but
somebody who very helpfully tells us
some things about this this handbook and
um
here sellers you know brings in the
three kinds of spiritual exercises and
he's tying this in with you know the
three topoi the three subject matters
that epictetus certainly himself
thinks are central in philosophy
sometimes this is called the three
disciplines and they're talked about in
different ways so like they'll talk
about the discipline of desire which is
actually the discipline of desire and of
uh aversion and also of the emotions the
discipline of action which is better
understood as the discipline of choice
right which has also to do with duties
and then the discipline of ascent which
has to do with all sorts of
epistemological matters including ascent
including impressions including all
these these other key ideas that really
fall into stoic logic
and
we're going to talk more about the
three-toe boy but this is how sellers
divides things up and he thinks that the
the um
and caridian can be divided up along the
lines of these three disciplines and
along the lines of
you know ethics physics and
logic
you know which is an interesting
interpretation and we'll we'll talk
about that in in a bit
and then you know ends with a you know
thing about the philosophical bios and
some some philosophical maxim so you
know he's providing an interesting
reinterpretation of the end caribbean
here and then he talks about the you
know this final chapter exercises in the
meditations of marcus aurelius now in
this chapter
he does talk about irelias
he talks a lot about epictetus first
because he's he's framing the
meditations in terms of epictetus's
three disciplines
and you know it's uh
it's plausible it makes sense to do that
he also hits on some of the things that
really key to marcus this cosmological
view of things the discussions of
impressions and judgments and there's a
great section here
in you know late in this chapter where
he talks about
these distinct stages
uh in in the analysis of impressions
there's a four-stage thing that i think
could be quite helpful
there's discussions of what are called
adequate impressions the cadillac decay
and
epistemological exercises in the
meditations and then we get to the
conclusion and so you know this is kind
of interesting the first section of it
is called towards a technical conception
of philosophy he doesn't mean philosophy
is technical in the sense of like it's
just a preserve for you know
those who are the the you know the
cognoscenti the knowers right us
academics or anything like that
technical means
techne
it's connected with an art that all of
us can actually
study and learn whether we do so in the
academy or not so he's you know
revisiting that um he talks about two
conceptions of philosophical knowledge
and you know the difference uh that some
observe between episteme uh knowledge
and wisdom either phronesis and sophia
and this is the stoics don't actually
view these as different from each other
and then he reasserts the importance of
philosophy and biography and then
he tells us there's essentially an
ancient philosophy three different kinds
of philosophical texts there's
literature that's concerned with
arguments and doctrines right you know
aristotle's nico mccain ethics you know
theoretical treaties commentaries like
alexander of aphrodisias and then
there's literature concerned with
actions the biographical literature
anecdotal material his you know
histories of people but there's also
literature concerned with spiritual
exercises escape these right
texts for guiding exercises such as
epictetus's handbook
texts written as exercises like marcus
aurelius's meditations and you know it's
a great way of looking at how
epictetus's ideas and aurelius's ideas
as we get them in these works are
connected with each other and then
there's this discussion of the technical
conception of philosophy i read some of
that to you earlier and you know this is
this notion that philosophy is a techne
it is not just an episteme a body of
knowledge arranged in a treatise
something that we teach in classes
it's it's a way of living
and so these are some of the really key
points about the work i hope i've given
you an adequate summary of what you
would find there
i'm always delighted to have a lot of
positive things to say about a work it's
not always the case but it is in fact
the situation with this book the art of
living the stoics on the nature and
function of philosophy
i mentioned already the style of the
work and this is not unique to this
particular book by john sellers he has a
very enviable
style
writing is an academic but writing in
such a way that the ordinary literate
person who's interested in philosophy
without a a strong technical background
in it can get a lot out of it it's it's
a really well written book and i think
if you read it you know it might require
going over passages several times but
it's going to be because the material
itself or the concepts are difficult
not because john sellers has made it
difficult for you so that's that's an
excellent thing to be able to say
um i think
that another really good point about
this work i mean to begin with
the scholarship is just
superb
you know
it's it's heavily
footnoted which i'm going to talk about
a little bit later there's all these
great discussions everything is being
referenced and explained
and you know john is one of these people
who has read and not just read but
studied
very very wild widely and not just in
ancient philosophy
he understands ancient philosophy
through
you know contemporary people today
talking about it but also the grand
sweep of history as well
so that's really quite admirable he's
attentive to the differences not just
between
philosophical schools like the
aristotelians versus the platonist or
the stoics versus the skeptics but also
within
a school itself like the stoics so you
know where for example
um
one stoic thinks one thing and another
thinks another thing you can count on
john to actually bring that to light and
to say okay these are you know differing
conceptions here let's not just blur
over these let's pay attention to what's
happening there another thing that i
think is really really great about this
book
is
following out these other distinctions
like you know his discussion of the
different kinds of arts and so thinking
very
seriously about what is what is this art
of living that we're calling philosophy
if we're looking at it in a stoic
perspective or we're looking at it in
other perspectives as well that's a
really solid
piece of not just scholarship but also
like deep thinking about these these
matters that is guided by the the you
know thinkers who he's engaging with um
the meaning of esthesis
that's something that is being explored
here as well a lot of people like to use
that word because it's a cool greek term
what does it actually mean you know it's
not meaning exactly the same thing
to plato as it is to the stoics and you
know being able to explain that i think
is is quite good
um
examining counter positions you know
thinking about aristotle's take on these
things or
thinking about the skeptics that entire
chapter
considering mostly sextus empiricus and
his views but you know
situating it within a a paradigm
provided by
skeptical philosophy in antiquity which
took over plato's academy by the way and
sextus you know is
uh you know responding later to both to
pyronism
and to academic skepticism so that's a
really great strength of the work i
think
i also find
that you know in chapter seven
rereading this
um
i actually you know i'm i'm pretty much
convinced by john seller's
reinterpretation
of the meditations in light of the three
disciplines
and i think it's it's it's a good
interpretation john sellers isn't the
only person obviously to bring this up
you know pure dough does as well but i
think what's in here is really really
quite a good
interpretation so it's plausible but
man it also provides you with sort of
like a model of what that kind of
interpretation ought to look like so
that's pretty cool as well
so you know a lot of very positive
things to say about this book
it's the kind of book that as i've said
before with a few other
reviews that i've done
as a researcher as a writer
you read a book like this and you're
like oh that is so good i wish i was
able to write a book like that myself so
there's a bit of not envy but emulation
involved as well in in reading this but
i think for
most other readers i mean they might
have that reaction but they're also
going to be like wow this is really
helpful for me
i only have two things that i'm going to
call problematic here and they're not
like deeply problematic they're they're
things where there can be
reasonable disagreement about these
matters so i'm i may be at odds
either with other readers or with with
john sellers on these sorts of things
and the first one is about his
interpretation of how the end caridian
or the handbook of epictetus is
structured in chapter
six you know i you know i think that
epictetus does have three topoi right i
i buy into that completely that
epictetus is originating this um i i
don't see that as as you know central to
stoic philosophy in general and i also
don't think that the three topoi line up
neatly
with um the physical the ethical and the
logical
so you know when sellers is saying that
sections two through twenty nine
the first of the three types of exercise
in the handbook is concerned with
desires and aversions and this can can
be seen to correspond to physics i'm
like
yeah i don't know about that that seems
a little bit too neat and here's here's
one of the reasons why i find
his interpretation here
plausible interesting but problematic
simplicius
who he brings up you know who wrote a
commentary on epictetuses and coridian
he also says well you know epictetus is
in caribbean is structured in these ways
and it you know falls into these
different sections and it doesn't map on
to what john sellers is doing
so you gotta say all right there's
there's
multiple
plausible
constructions organizations of epictetus
and caribbean this one can't be just the
you know automatic intuitive one it's a
plausible one but you know there's
multiple plausible ones so that's one
thing to say right now the other thing
to say
i'm actually i don't see it as
problematic but i can see how some
readers might view things as problematic
i'm going to show you a typical
set of pages
all right so you look at that right
there what are you seeing
well there's a lot of footnote right
and almost every single page of the book
has a lot of footnotes
if you don't like that you're going to
be bothered by that in this book and
you're going to be constantly going oh
i'm missing something in the footnotes
right
if you like footnotes which i do i i
grew up as a reader reading books where
they were extensively footnoted and um
oftentimes there's really cool
discussions in the footnotes i look at
them as sort of like oh these like
little side
conversations if you like that sort of
thing that's not problematic at all to
you and you're going to love it because
again just about every single page in
the main body of the text has got some
some footnotes there's a few pages that
don't have footnotes but they're uh
they're the rarity so those are the only
things that i really find problematic
about this this book
final thoughts if you've made it this
far in the review i think you've figured
out that i think this is a really great
book that if you have any interest in
philosophy
as an art of living if you have an
interest in stoicism if you have an
interest in ancient philosophy in
general you want this book this should
be on your shelf it should be part of
your
library
so you know i highly recommend it
unqualifiedly
recommend it
i would say get this i also want to say
thank you once again to
dominic
escorpessel for sending me this copy of
the book i know it's taken me a little
bit longer to get around to a review as
promised but i have now delivered on
that promise so thanks to him thanks to
john for for writing this excellent book
and
that's it i i highly recommend it
you